so i've copy and pasted this question
from the exercises on khan academy it
says sort the following expressions from
least to greatest based on the
coordinates of the rectangle below so we
need to figure out what y z and x are
and then we need to sort them so let's
let's first look at well first let's
look at y and this is a little bit
counter-intuitive because they're using
the variable y to represent the
x-coordinate to represent the
x-coordinate of this point so let's see
if we can figure out what the
x-coordinate of this point is well it's
a rectangle the x-coordinate of this
point right over here is going to be the
same as the x coordinate of this point
they sit on the same vertical line the
way that it's drawn so if this has an x
coordinate of x equals 4 then this is
going to have an x coordinate of 4 and
now we use the variable y for the x
coordinate which is a little strange but
this is going to be the point 4
comma 7.
so y
is equal to 4.
now let's see what we can figure out
about z
well z is going to is the y coordinate
for let me use another color here z is
the y coordinate for this point now what
other point has the same y coordinate
well it's going to be at the same level
i guess you could say in the in the
vertical direction it's going to sit on
the same horizontal line so it's going
to have the same y coordinate as this
point now this point has a y coordinate
of 3 so this point's y chord it needs to
be 3 or we could say that z
is equal to 3. so this is going to be
equal to 3 and then last but not least
we need to figure out what x is and x is
the x coordinate and let me just in
another color x is the x coordinate for
this point
well this x coordinate is going to be
the same thing as the x coordinate for
this point up here which is equal to 2.
they sit on the same vertical line they
both sit on the line x equals 2.
and so x
x is going to be 2. it is the x
coordinate it is also the variable x so
this is going to be 2. so if we wanted
to if we want to sort them from least to
greatest
x is the least
then we would go it's actually the exact
opposite of what we have here would be x
then z then y two then three then four
so actually let me get the exercise out
and just check our answer so x is the
least then z is in the middle and then y
is the largest we could check our answer
we've got it right